we are convinced that full-time health
service can be rendered New York State
citizens most effectively under a
district plan of administration ready
state health districts and sub districts
are now in operation or will be an
operation at an early date the five
county health departments are integral
parts of their respective districts
suitable quarters are provided for
district offices such as those at Albany
and Buffalo a full time district state
health officers in charge of each
district civil service qualifications
for new district officers include a
medical degree a postgraduate course in
public health and five years full time
experience the district officers the
commissioner's representative and
authorized to act for him he has
available for technical advice the
directors of the eleven divisions and
two district health directors
besides the district officer the average
district staff includes an assistant
district officer a district supervising
nurse one or more engineers supervising
infield public health nurses and a
clerical staff full records are kept in
all district offices such as syphilis
and tuberculosis registers maintained
checked according to the status of each
case district officers conduct the state
program through 798 local health
officers and five county health
commissioners there are frequent
conferences with local health officers
when serious epidemics or unusual
circumstances occurred assistance is
given to the district officer by
temporary assignments from other
districts or the central office district
staffs are flexible and not subject to
local authorities an important function
of the district officer is the
preliminary field training of young
physicians and participation in
selection of physicians for academic
postgraduate training and careers in
public health the district states
supervising nurse supervisors nurses
employed by the department as well as
many employed locally she has a
responsibility for the training and
selection of nurses similar to that of
the district officer for physicians the
district officer has a part in all the
department's major activity
New York State is now conducting an
experimental field study to determine
the feasibility of nursing delivery
service as part of the generalized
nursing program in a rural County
because of persistently high infant
mortality preponderance of home
deliveries and maternal deaths chiefly
in rural sections st. Lawrence County
was selected conferences were held of
state and local health officials and
with local physicians Hospital and
welfare representatives the county was
zoned for accessibility 10 nurses in a
supervising nurse who was midwife
trained were assigned the nurses were
equipped with cars fitted bags and
electric lanterns as well as strong snow
shovels nurses instruct prospective
mothers and help them make their
preparation
obstetric packages for use by the
doctors and home deliveries were made
and assembled in WPA sewing rooms and by
volunteer groups of women the nurses
supervise the work and assemble the
packages for sterilizing at the local
milk plant
the doctor arriving for a delivery finds
a nurse in charge room and patient
prepared and hot water ready towels and
sterile supplies are waiting in the
package the electric lantern is better
than the kerosene lamp and the nurses
are willing efficient helper nurse
returns next morning to bathe baby care
for mother and instruct neighbor or
relative this doctor believes the
service is meeting a real need and
appreciates the work of the nurses who
in addition to general duties have
assisted at 84 home deliveries and
supervised 431 patients during the first
six months of the demonstration
Engineering is a major branch of Public
Health work reduction in typhoid fever
in New York State has been due in large
measure to the control exercised by the
division of Sanitation over water milk
and sewage disposal engineers supervise
the sanitary quality of water supply to
more than 12 million persons over 90% of
the water consumed in New York State
receives treatment many water
purification plants have been
constructed as a result of
recommendations made by Department
engineers water supplies are inspected
frequently and subjected to routine
bacteriological tests at regular
intervals in milk foreign disease
outbreaks all suspected cows are
examined by a department veteran area
for assured safety the department urges
the use of pasteurized milk pasteurizing
plants are inspected frequently
routine tests used in laboratory control
of milk supplies are they direct
microscopic count to determine quality
of the raw product the phosphatase tests
to determine the thoroughness of
pasteurization of the milk and the coli
test to detect contamination after
pasteurization pollution extremes is
being abated by requiring instill a
sewage treatment plant regularly
inspected by Department engineers more
than 100 plants had been constructed in
New York State since 1930 plans for all
storage improvements must receive
approval as the Division of Sanitation
prior to construction in five years the
value of works represented by such plans
has amounted to more than 100 million
dollars mm swimming pools throughout the
state are supervised by the division as
well as 3,000 summer and tourist camps
which provide accommodations annually
for 2 million persons routine work as a
Division of Sanitation is expedited by
the assignments of district engineers
and milk sanitarians to the staffs of
the various state health systems
enabling prompt service to be rendered
in connection with any sanitary problems
arising within the district
New York State's program for the control
of pneumonia embraces a variety of
activities and the pneumococcus serums
for the treatment of the five types for
which it has been proved a value are
produced in dispensed at no cost to
physicians
diagnostic serums for six types are
dispensed to 112 approved laboratories
and typing stations sputum is examined
immediately by the noise out technique
current flecks are mixed with each type
of serum and examined blood cultures are
highly important in cases in the morning
extensive Graduate Medical Education is
being undertaken in cooperation with the
New York State Medical Society every
available means of reaching the medical
profession is being utilized in the
belief that earlier diagnosis and wider
and more adequate use of the serums now
available may result the need for
teaching the general public the
seriousness of certain of the early
symptoms of pneumonia and the urgency of
medical care is recognized the mere
availability of serum is insufficient
unless an enlightened public makes its
earliest possible skillful nursing care
is important public health nurses
throughout the state are devoting
increasing time to bedside care as well
as to teaching demonstrations for
pneumonia cases the New York State
Nurses Association is cooperating with
the state health department in graduate
education of its members research has
resulted in further advances in the
methods of production and refinement of
the therapeutic serums a series of 1660
type 1 pneumonia cases treated with
serum produced and dispensed by the
department was accumulated during the
first 20 months of the program fairly
complete data are available on all of
these and their careful analysis gives
promise of adding substantially to our
knowledge of the limitations requisites
and potentialities of serum treatment as
a method of pneumonia control
the state of New York owns and maintains
the oldest cancer research laboratory in
the world established in 1898 this
hospital located in Buffalo and called
the State Institute for the Study of
malignant disease has research
facilities and all branches of science
and the bed capacity of a hundred and
thirty after completion of a new wing
the state Institute is equipped with a
complete surgical department and modern
x-ray and radium appliances for the
diagnosis and treatment of malignant
disease
there are 8 grams of radium estes state
institute - in solution and 6 grams of
the insoluble salt as much radium as is
possessed by any hospital in the world
as radium and solution disintegrates it
gives off a gas which can be utilized
only after it is removed from the
solution by means of oil and mercury
pumps modern shockproof x-ray machines
are available for the treatment of
malignant growth last year 3645 new
patients were admitted to this hospital
for diagnosis and treatment this service
is free to all residents of New York
State who are recommended for
examination and treatment by their
family physician an expensive
educational program is being carried on
for the purpose of dispelling fear of
cancer and impressing upon the laity
that there is the cure if the disease is
recognized in its early stages it is
always borne in mind that this is
primarily an institute for the study of
malignant disease and every opportunity
is embraced to conduct a continuous
program of research in the unsolved
problems of cancer control
since 1916 New York State has been
rebuilding its crippled children and now
spends more than one and a half million
dollars annually on their rehabilitation
and education through efforts of the
orthopedic nurses and family physicians
they are brought to clinics for
examination by an orthopedic surgeon if
the child has a condition that can
definitely be improved arrangements are
made to admit the youngster to a local
institution that meets the state
requirements or to the New York State
reconstruction home at West Haverstraw
here specialized surgery is available
when needed
hospital care by specially trained
nurses guards the child if an operation
is necessary physiotherapy aids his
recovery
training teachers worked with him so
that when he goes home he will be able
to follow along with his schoolmates
outside activities keep the youngsters
busy and happy some of them have reached
a point where their physical condition
will permit them to carry on restricted
activities on the playground a 12-piece
Orchestra furnishes music at the
institution and plays at the annual
State Health Conference at Saratoga
Springs you are listening to it now
playing a selection which is used as the
theme music of the state health
department's weekly radio program when
the patient is ready to leave the
reconstruction home she is returned to
her home and family physician under the
care of the orthopedic nurse and the
field clinic service conducted by the
State Department of Health
New York State's tuberculosis taste
finding program is based on the fact
that the control of tuberculosis depends
on the prevention of spread of
tuberculosis infection this can be
accomplished by segregation treatments
and education of the open cases of
tuberculosis and by going out into the
field and finding cases tuberculosis is
a family problem and the most fertile
source for finding new cases is among
close household contacts of those having
the disease
early discovery of tuberculosis means
early recovery to that end our efforts
should be devoted early tuberculosis is
not characterized by any special signs
or symptoms and we should investigate
other possible fertile sources for
finding early cases these men have been
x-rayed x-ray is our most valuable ally
in discovering the disease in its
earliest stages and these workers to
have been x-ray
these normal school students mostly
young women at the age of greatest
susceptibility to adult type pulmonary
tuberculosis are tuberculin tested and
x-rayed yearly until graduation
consecutive admissions to General
Hospital's directly
this patient had advanced disease when
discovered his treatment is for long his
prognosis is dubious
the cost to himself family and community
is great on the other hand this patient
was discovered early and after a
suitable length of observation and
treatment as well on the road to
complete rehabilitation it is real
economy to spend money and effort to
find the early case
public health programs are effective
only so far as they are taken to
understood and accepted by the public
frequent press stories are released to
news services local correspondence and
the 130 dailies and 540 weeklies in new
york state health news is sent every
week to 14,000 physicians nurses
hospitals libraries public health
workers and other interested individuals
and agencies qualified experts prepare
special stories and pamphlets on health
subject during the first nine months of
1937 1 million two hundred and
seventy-five thousand of these
educational pamphlets were distributed
from the beginning visual instruction
has been foremost among health education
aides in New York now sixteen and thirty
five-millimeter cameras record the
progress of Public Health and silence
and sound projectors spread the story is
told in their library of fifty film
subjects the health mobile rolls over
paved roads and country lanes with this
equipment as well as exhibits and
displays and other portable educational
materials probably the most intimate
approach into the homes of the people
with the state's health messages radio
each week since August 1933 helps plays
written accident produced entirely
within the State Department of Health
have been presented from WGY Schenectady
now all by means of electrical
transcription recordings these programs
are broadcast throughout the state over
a chain of 19 other radio stations then
these electrical transcription records
are available by means of portable sound
equipment for use before Grange's
parent-teacher associations school
classes women's organizations service
clubs and similar groups from Radio
alone since the beginning of the week we
play series responses have been received
from 745 different cities and villages
in the state health education is
reaching the people of New York State